[موسيقى]
وهذه اخبار الساعه
واشنطن تشكك باحتماليه استخدام اسلحه
امريكيه في هجوم بيلجرود وتؤكد انها لا
تشجع او تسمح بضربات داخل روسيا
في السودان هدنه ومعارك صوت الرصاص يعلو
في ام درمان و واشنطن تلوح بادواتها للرد
على انتهاكات وقف اطلاق النار
في ازمه الديون الامريكيه شروط الجمهوريين
تزيد الضغط على بايدن وتحذيرات من نفاذ
الاموال
الملياردير الامريكي الاشهر مهدد بفضيحه
علاقه غراميه مع روسيه وهويه مرسل الرساله
مفاجئه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه وبدايتها من
تطورات الوضع في روسيا والهجوم على
الروسيه حيث شككت الولايات المتحده في صحه
تقارير تفيد باستخدام اسلحه امريكيه في
هذا الهجوم وقدمت لاوكرانيا او قدمت هذه
الاسلحه لاوكرانيا في الهجوم على روسيا
واكد المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه ان واشنطن لا تشجعوا على تنفيذ
ضربات داخل روسيا
هذا واعلن حاكم ومقاطعه الروسيه الغاء
نظام المكافحه الارهاب في المقاطعه بعد
يوم من فرضه على خلفيه تسلل مجموعه
تخريبيه اوكرانيه على حد وصف المسؤول
الروسي كما اكد حاكم اجلاء نحو 100 شخص من
بلدتي
في المقاطعه فيما اعلنت السلطات مقتل شخص
واصابه ثلاثه عشر جراء الهجوم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
نتابع منا موسكو مع عبد الجواد رشد
المراسل العربيه عبد الجواد هل هناك اي
تفاصيل اضافيه او اي اثباتات تثبت وجود
الاسلحه الامريكيه وان اوكرانيا وراء هذا
الهجوم على الروسيه
مساء الخير صهيب وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
قامت بنشر مقطع فيديو يظهر هذه المعدات
طبعا وزاره الدفاع تتحدث عن انها امريكيه
الصنع وقامت يعني واشنطن بتزويد كيف بهذه
المعدات لابد من لفت الانتباه صهيب بان
النشرات الاخبار اليوم على معظم القنوات
المحليه والداخليه الروسيه قامت بعرض هذه
المعدات وتحدثت عن تفاصيل مصدرها بانها
امريكيه الصنع صهيب لابد من الاشاره الى
العاجل بان التقارير والاخبار الوارده
الان من تتحدث وتظهر مقاطع فيديو فيها
اصوات انفجارات عاليه انباء تتحدث عن ان
هذه الاصوات هي ناتجه عن عمل القوات
المسلحه الروسيه حيث قد تكون تقصف مواقع
تابعه للقوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه هذه
الانباء العاجله الوارده من هناك نعم يعني
الان هي تقصف مواقع هذه القوات الاوكرانيه
داخل الاراضي الروسيه تقصد
صهيب يعني الوجهه غير معروفه لكن طبعا
حاكم منذ قليل وتحدث عن ان كافه المناطق
الان في الاقليم هي نظيفه وقد تم ابعاد او
القضاء على من دخل اليها يوم الامس لذلك
طبعا متوقع بان هذه الضربات موجهه نحو
الداخل الاوكراني حسب القراءه السياسيه
طيب لكن عبد الجواد على ذكر حاكم بيل قرود
ماذا يعنيه نظام
الارهاب او وقف النظام العمل به في
المتعلق بمكافحه الارهاب على ما اذكر ما
الذي يقصده حاكم
بهذا الاجراء
يعني العمل بهذا النظام بدا يوم امس
مباشره بعد هذه العمليه صهيب طبعا هي
اجراءات قاسيه تدخل فيها المدينه المدينه
من عمليه تفتيش وتمحيص في الاوراق تفتيش
السيارات اقامه حواجز التدقيق بشكل كبير
على كل ما هو داخل وخارج في المدينه
وتحركات المواطنين والسيارات والحافلات
وغير ذلك لكن طبعا مع الغاء هذا القانون
اليوم بقيت الكثير من الامور نتابع في
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي وخاصه على
تيليجرام بان طبعا هناك العديد من التطبيق
في اوراق معظم الناس يعني حواجز على مداخل
ومخارج المدن والقرى وخاصه المناطق
الحدوديه لذلك طبعا مع الغاء هذا القانون
لازال العمل قائما بما يخص مكافحه الارهاب
والتدقيق في كل التفاصيل لجميع الاشخاص في
تلك المنطقه الحديديه
شكرا
جزيلا لك عبد الجواد مباشره من موسكو
الرئيس الاوكراني فلونسكي يعود لرفع
معنويات مقاتليه مباشره بعد سقوط ضخمه
اختار جبهه بشرق اوكرانيا للقيام باخر
زيارته الميدانيه رئيس الاوكراني
ظهر مواقع متقدمه على الجبهه في منطقه
الدفاع
مارينكا حيث تجري معارك مع الجيش الروسي
منذ اشهر الفرصه كانت مواتيه ايضا لتكريم
عناصر من مشاه البحريه الاوكرانيه بمناسبه
اليوم العالمي لهذه القوات زياره زيلينسكي
هذه تاتي في توقيت حساس وذلك تزامنا مع
اعلان القوات فاغنر الروسيه السيطره على
مدينه باخموت وتراجع زيلينسكي عن اعترافه
بسقوط باخمت مؤكدا ان قواته لا تزال في
المدينه لكنها لا تسيطر عليها من جهتها
قالت نائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكرانيه هنا
مليار ان
وقواتها لا تزال تسيطر على منطقه الطائرات
مضيفه ان المع ركه من اجل السيطره على
المرتفعات على الاطراف في شمال وجنوب
الضواحي مستمر
وفي هذا الخضم اذا لا يزال والشغل الشاغل
الكياب هو ايجاد موارد اضافيه من الاسلحه
من اجل تنفيذ هجومها المضاد ولا تزال
امدادات الاسلحه الغربيه تتدفق نحو كييف
التي باتت تتطلع الان الى استلام طائره اف
16 الحربيه الامريكيه في اخر تطورات ملف
هذه الطائرات الطائرات الاف 16 اعلن مسؤول
السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي
جوزيف عن بدء تدريب الطيارين الاوكرانيين
على قياده مقاتلات الاف سته عشر في العديد
من البلدان هذا في الوقت الذي اعلن فيه
وزير الدفاع الالماني بوريس بيستوريوس ان
برلين تدرس دعم تحالف يهدف لتزويد
اوكرانيا بمقاتلات اف 16 في المقابل فان
الكريمينال الروسي ابدع اعتراضا واضحا على
هذه الخطوه حيث شدد على ان تزويد اوكرانيا
بمقاتلات حديثه من طراز اف 16 ينطوي على
مخاطر واضحه
وروسيا تحقق اذا اهم تقدم لها في اوكرانيا
منذ عده اشهر بعد نجاحها في السيطره على
مدينه باقمت تقدم اعاد الثقه للمعسكر
الروسيه الذي عاش فتره شك بعد عجزه عن
تحقيق اي انجاز كبير على ارض الميدان
التقدم الاخير عكس استقرارا داخليا
وبالتاكيد جاء على لسان الاستخبارات
الالمانيه فبهذا الخصوص قال رئيس جهاز
الاستخبارات الخارجيه الالماني برونوكال
انه لم يتم حتى الان رصد اي مؤشرات على
ضعف نظام الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
بعد اكثر من عام على بدايه العمليه
العسكريه في اوكرانيا كما اضاف ذات
المتحدث ان روسيا لا تزال في وضع يمكنها
من شر حرب على المدى الطويل بالعناصر
المجنده حديثا
[موسيقى]
الى السودان تبدو اتفاقيات وقف اطلاق
النار هناك مجرده حبر على ورق ليس الا
فمنذ اندلاع الازمه السودانيه لم تمر اي
هدنه دون ان يكسر او يكسر صمتها ذوي اطلاق
النار الحال لم يختلف في اول اتفاق رسمي
لاطلاق النار فرغم دخوله حيز التنفيذ الا
ان اصوات الرصاص والغارات الجويه سمعت في
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم وبعيدا عن
اتفاق اطلاق وقف اطلاق النار اتهمت وزاره
الصحه في ولايه الخرطوم اتهمت الدعم
السريع بالتمركز في المستشفيات وقالت في
بيان لها ان الدعم السريع واصل لاستهداف
المستمر للقطاع الصحي بكل مكوناته
واستهداف المرضى والكوادر الصحيه وتابع
البيان ان عدد المستشفيات التي تتمركز
فيها قوات الدعم السريع ارتفع الى 28
مستشفى وست مؤسسات صحيه حيويه مشيرا الى
انها تستولي ايضا على احدى وعشرين عربه
اسعاف
تبعاتها الحرب على الاوضاع الانسانيه بدات
تتجلى اكثر فاكثر مع استمرار المعارك وهو
ما دفع العديد من المنظمات الدوليه الى دق
ناقوس الخطر من بينها مفوضيه الامم
المتحده لشؤون اللاجئين التي حذرت من ان
عدد الذين يلجاون الى تشاد هربا من
السودان يتزايد بسرعه كبيره اضافت
المفوضيه ان عدد الاشخاص الذين فروا من
السودان نحو تشاد بات يتراوح ما بين 60
و90 الف شخص كما دعت المفوضيه الى ضروره
نقل الوافدين الجدد الى تشاد الى اقرب
مخيمات للاجئين بشكل عاجل خصوصا مع اقتراب
موسم الامطار
هذا وقالت وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه ان
لديها ادوات للتعامل مع انتهاك وقف اطلاق
النار في السودان ولن تتردد باستخدام تلك
الادوات في الوقت المناسب اوضح المتحدث
باسم الوزاره ماثيوميلر ان واشنطن ومجموعه
مراقبه الهدنه بالسودان تناقش مزاعم
انتهاك وقف النار
نتابع اذا تطورات المشهد في السودان من
الخرطوم على الصحفي عمار ابو شيبه ومن ام
درمان الصحفي في مكتب العربيه في السودان
شهد نادر ومن ولايه الجزيره موفد العربيه
محمد عثمان مرحبا بكم جميعا عمار ابو شيبه
ابدى معك في الخرطوم حوالي اثنتي عشره
هدنه في السودان سقطت منذ دقائقها الاولى
مع بدء تطبيقها هل ترى مؤشرات مختلفه في
هذه الهدنه ام ستكون كسابقاتها
اهلا بك صهيب واهلا بالزملاء الكرام دعم
هنالك مؤشرات مختلفه باعتبار انها صمتت
لساعات كثيره جدا خاصه في الاوقات الاولى
من الصباح هنا في الشرقيه العاصمه الخرطوم
استمرت حتى اخر النهار وبدانا نستمع بين
فتره واخرى هنا في شرق العاصمه الخرطوم
الى اصوات اعيره الناريه لم ترتقي الى
المدفعيه الثقيله هذه احد الاصوات التي
نسمعها ما بين فتره واخرى ربما هي عمليات
نعم ربما هي عمليات كروه فار او حتى قنص
في عدد من المناطق المحازيه لهذه المناطق
وتنتشر فيها عدد من القوات العسكريه على
الارض ولكن قبل لحظات ايضا من الدخول لهذا
المباشر كنا نستمع الى اصوات رصاص ولكن
بكثافه استمرت لعدد من الدقائق ثم صمتت من
جديد وايضا هذه الاصوات تتكرر بين فتره
واخرى هذه المؤشرات جميعها صهيب تشير بشكل
واضح الى انه كان هنالك التزاما جزئيا من
ثمه عدد من جديد اصوات البنادق في عدد من
المناطق في الشرقيه العاصمه الخرطوم اما
المناطق في وسط العاصمه الخاصه محيط
القياده العامه للجيش ومطار الخرطوم
والدولي وحتى القصر الرئاسي ومنطقه السوق
العربي لم تسجل فيها اصوات اشتباك
باستثناء منطقه وسط العاصمه الخرطوم التي
تقع في احياء الجوز وجزء من مداخل حي
الرمال حيث تم تسجيل عدد من الاشتباكات ما
بين القوات المتواجده هناك قوات الدعم
السريع والجيش واستمرت لعدد من الساعات
وهنالك مصادر طبيه محليه غير رسميه اشارت
الى سقوط عدد من الاصابات وسط المواطنين
خروقات مستمره ولكن وان كانت قليله
بالمقرنه مع الهدى السابقه شهد نادر اسالك
كذلك عن ام درمان بدل فتن في مستشفى ام
درمان حسب بيان وزاره الصحه قوات الدعم
السريع قامت بالتمركز في هذه المستشفى
اضافه الى حوالي 29 مستشفى اخر ما قصه
تمركز الدعم السريع في المستشفيات
نعم صهيب بحسب بيان وزاره الصحه فان 28
مستشفى ما تزال قوات الدعم السريع تتمركز
بداخلها هو بيان اصدرته صباح هذا هذا
اليوم رغم دخول سريان الهدنه دخولها حيث
التنفيذ منذ مساء الامس كذلك اضافه الى ست
مؤسسات صحيه حيويه الوزاره رات انه لم يتم
انفاس او ما نصض عليه الهدنه من عمليات
انسحاب من المرافق
الصحيه والمستشفيات حتى يتسنى للكوادر
الطبيه والقائمين على امر الصحه بالعوده
وبحثي كيفيه اعاده هذه المستشفيات الى
الى الخدمه لتقديم الخدمات الطبيه كذلك
صهيب الهيئه هيئه مياه ولايه الخرطوم قالت
بان
الثلاث محطات من جمله 13 محطه ها كانت قد
سيطرت عليها قوات الدعم السريع ايضا ما
تزال تتواجد بها لم تنسحب فاكبر هذه
المحطات هي محطه المياه مدينه الخرطوم
بحري التي عاش جل مواطنيها عطش ممتد لاكثر
من شهر نطاق خروج هذه المحطه التي تطوخ
حوالي الثلاثمائه الف متر مكعب من مياه
الشرب بشكل يومي هذا في في جانب ما نصد
عليه الهدنه انسانيا عسكريا صهيب اليوم
ايضا في مدينه ام درمان مضى اليوم بدا
اليوم هادئا غابت اصوات البنادق ولكنها
عاودت منتصف نهار هذا هذا اليوم حيث شهدت
عده انحاء مدينه درمان اشتباكات بالاسلحه
الخفيفه في مدينه الثوره كذلك جنوبي مدينه
ام درمان اضافه الى انه نما الى علمنا
بوجود اشتباكات متقطعه في هذه في هذه في
هذه الاثناء في عده مناطق في مدينه ام
درمان
نذهب الى منطقه اخرى نذهب الى ولايه
الجزيره محمد عثمان مرحبا من جديد ولايه
الجزيره هي ولايه محاذيه للعاصمه الخرطوم
وهي من الولايات او ربما الولايه الاكثر
استقبالا للنازحين الفارين من المعارك بين
الجيش والدعم السريع في العاصمه الخرطوم
هل ما تزال اعداد النازحين تصل باعداد
كبيره الى ولايه الجزيره
نعم الاعداد كبيره خاصه صهيب مع اشتداد
المعارك في الخرطوم وفي شوارع الخرطوم بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع ولان هذه
الولايه هي من الولايات المحادده لولايه
الخرطوم بطبيعه الحال حالها كحال بقيه
الولايات المحادده لولايه الخرطوم غير ان
هذه الولايه كان لها النصيب الاكبر
والنصيب الوافر من استقبال اعداد كبيره
جدا من الفارينه من ويلات الحرب في شوارع
الخرطوم وبالتالي هذه الولايه استقبلت
اعداد وما زالت تستقبل اعداد كبيره جدا
تقول الاعداد يعني التي اطلقتها مفوضيه
العون الانساني هنا في السودان ان هنالك
اكثر من 600 الف شخص يعني وصلوا الى هذه
الولايه التي تعتبر ايضا ولايه ممر وصولا
الى الولايات الشرقيه ووصولا ايضا الى
ولايه سنار وولايه النيل الابيض والولايات
الشرقيه ولايه كسلا والقضارف وكذلك ايضا
ولايه البحر الاحمر وبالتالي
هذه الولايه امتياز كبير يتعلق ايضا
ان الطريق الى بقيه الولايات يعبر من هذه
الولايه تحديدا كما ان هذه الولايه ايضا
نسبه الامان بها كبيره لا وجود في هذه
الولايه لعناصر من الدعم السريع كما ان
هذه الولايه ايضا بها الخدمات الاساسيه
مستقره نوعا ما نحن نتحدث عن مياه شرب
ونتحدث ايضا عن توفير الخدمات الاساسيه من
من الغذاء وكذلك ايضا توفر المستشفيات
العامه وكذلك ايضا المستشفيات التخصصيه
صهيب على ذكر المستشفيات محمد كيف هو
الوضع الصحي في ولايه الجزيره خاصه مع
الامراض المزمنه يعني والناس تعاني خاصه
في ضوء اشتداد المعارك في الخرطوم اصحاب
الامراض المزمنه لم يجدوا المستشفيات التي
يتلقون فيها العلاج هل الوضع الصحي وضع
المستشفيات افضل في الجزيره
نعم هو افضل مقارنه يعني مع بقيه الولايات
نحن نتحدث عن ان هذه الولايه هي تفكر الان
في الخروج من مرحله الصدمه الى مرحله
الصمود امام هذه الموجات الكبيره وهذه
التدفقات الكبيره للقادمين من مدينه
الخرطوم تعلم ان واحده من مشاكل النظام
الصحي ان هنالك كانت كل المستشفيات
الكبيره كل المراكز التخصصيه الكبيره كانت
موجوده في الخرطوم وبالتالي في مرمى
النيران وبعد خروج هذه المؤسسات الصحيه
والمستشفيات من الخدمه كانت الانظار تتجه
الى هذه الولايه مدينه ود مدني وبالتحديد
يعني مركز القلب ومراكز غسيل الكلى وكذلك
ايضا الجانب الاهم والجانب الابرز فيما
يتعلق
بالتوفر الادويه المتعلقه
بالامراض الخبيثه او امراض السرطان
والاورام هذه الولايه يعني امامها تحدي
كبير جدا ومرحله الصمود امام هذه التدفقات
الكبيره والمرضى الذين جاؤوا من الخرطوم
بحثا عن غسيل الكلى بحثا عن الادويه
المتعلقه بالسرطان بحثا عن العمليات
المنقذه للحياه نحن نتحدث عن العمليات
عمليات القلب المفتوح وما الى ذلك
وبالتالي النظام الصحي في هذه الولايه
امام تحدي كبير تحدي الصمود امام هذه
الاعداد الكبيره شكرا جزيلا لك محمد عثمان
موفد العربيه الى ولايه الجزيره الشكر
كذلك لك من الخرطوم عمار ابو شيبه ومن ام
درمان شاهدينار
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه على البيت
الابيض يؤكد ان بايدن ورئيس مجلس النواب
متفقا على ان التخلف عن سداد الدين غير
مطروح
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد هل باتت الطريق الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان نحو ولايه ثالثه
معبده بعد حصوله على تاييد مرشح الرئاسه
المنهزم في الجوله الاولى سنان اوغان
الاكيد ان تاييد اوغان شكل دفعه مهمه
لاردوغان دعم اوغان لاردوغان لم يمر دون
خلق جدل واسع سيما بعد تداول اخبار عن
مساومه اردوغان لاوغان مقابل منحه منصبا
حكوميا في حال فوته اردوغان لم يتاخر في
نفي هذه الاخبار مشيرا الى انه لم يضع اي
شرط مقابل الحصول على تاييد
اما فيما يتعلق بمطالب اوغان التي تخص ملف
اللاجئين اوضح اردوغان انه تمت اعاده 450
الف لاجئ الى بلادهم والهدف سيكون اعاده
توطين مليون لاجئ اخرين في شمال سوريا
على الطرف الاخر وفي اول تعليق له على
قرار اوغان بدعم رئيس تركيا اردوغان وعدل
المرشح الرئاسي كما الكلج منافسه منافس
اردوغان في الجوله الثانيه وعد بانقاذ
تركيا من الارهاب واللاجئين في حال فوزه
حسب تعبيره نشر في تدوينه على تويتر قال
فيها انه من الواضح من الذي يؤيد بيع هذا
الوطن الجميل واضف بالقول انه قادم لانقاذ
هذا البلد من الارهاب واللاجئين
معنا من اسطنبول دكتور سمير صارحه الاستاذ
في العلاقات الدوليه دكتور سمير اهلا بك
معنا لماذا انحاز اوغان لاردوغان
مساء الخير للجميع اولا ربما لانه وجد انه
له حسبات سياسيه خاصه به تدفعه لاتخاذ
موقف من هذا النوع في العلن هو يقول انه
لا يوجد اي مساومه بين الجانبين هو قرار
ذاتي مرتبط
بلعبه التوازنات السياسيه القائمه لكن انا
اظن انه الاجابه على هذا السؤال ستكون
اوضح بعد الخروج من الجوله الثانيه
للانتخابات يعني في الاسابيع القليله
القادمه في حال فوز الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان في الجوله الثانيه ربما قد نرى
اكثر يعني
موقع ودور سنان اوغان هل ربما يعني يكون
عندنا مفاجات سياسيه في العلاقه ما هو على
مستوى حزب العداله والتنميه ام لا هذه
براي النقطه الاساسيه الان التي نتابعها
نعم طيب ولكن السؤال في المواقف الخاصه
بترحيل اللاجئين
يعني سنان اوغامي يحسب على اليمين
المحافظ في في تركيا هو كان يطالب ويقول
بانه يريد اخراج كل اللاجئين وهو الامر
الذي يطالب به وقاله ايضا صراحه
فبدا في هذا الملف بالتحديد اقرب الى منه
الى اردوغان فبرايك ما نوع
التسويات التي حصلت بين الرجلين
الان في نقطه اولى برايي انه سنان اوغان
كان مرشح تحالف الاجداد كما تعرف وهو غير
موجود غير منتسب الى اي حزب سياسي في
تركيا ترشح بشكل مستقل دعمه حزب النصر حزب
ظفر الذي يقوده
بعد الان قرار
وقال دعم الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان انفرط
عقد هذا التحالف تحالف الاجداد وبدا شريكه
السابق اذا جاز التعبير بالتنسيق الان مع
كمال غدا صباحا احتمال ان يكون هناك توقيع
بروتوكول جديد بين كمال وبينها
حول تفاهمات جديده كلا الجانبين الان
يحسبان على الجناح القومي المتشدد في
تركيا كيف سيكون شال من تفاهمات بين كمال
القدس غدا مع هذه النقطه في غايه الاهميه
لانه منذ الان بدانا نسمع انتقادات داخل
حتى صفوف الطاوله السداسيه حزب الشعوب
الديمقراطيه الذي دعم كمال في الجوله
الاولى كما تعرف انت ايضا في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه بدا منذ الان يوجه رسائل الى
كمال انه اتفاق من هذا النوع قد يقلب
الطاوله مجددا على مستوى المعارضه وهذا
يعطي الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان الكثير من
الحظوظ والفرص يكون في جوله ثانيه يدخلها
ويخرج منها منتصرا بشكل اسهل بكثير من
الجوله الاولى
سنرى ذلك ايضا يوم الثامن والعشرين من
اسطنبول دكتور سمير صالحه الاستاذ في
العلاقات الدوليه كنت معنا من اسطنبول
[موسيقى]
قال البيت الابيض ان اجتماع الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن ورئيس مجلس النواب كيفن
ماكارتي بشان سداد الدين الامريكي كان
ايجابيا واوضحت المتحدثه باسم البيت
الابيض كارين جون كير ان بايدن كارد في
متفقان على ان التخلف عن سداد الدين امر
غير مطروح على طاوله النقاشات مشيره الى
وجود مجال للاتفاق على سداد الدين وشددت
على ان عواقب التخلف عن سداد الديون لاول
مره ستكون وخيمه على الشعب والاقتصاد
رغم فشل اجتماعي الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
ورئيسي مجلس النواب كبن مكارتي بالتوصل
الى اتفاق حول سقف الدين التفاؤل موجود
الى طاوله التفاوض اكد انه ما يعملان على
التوصل الى حل وسط بشان الميزانيه قبل
الاول من يونيو
الجمهوريون القوا باللوم على الرئيس بايدن
واعاد اتهامه بالتاخر في اجراء المفاوضات
مع مكارتي واكدوا تمسكهم بشروطهم كما اوضح
زعيمهم في مجلس النواب
الذي رايناه في الايام القليله الماضيه من
جو بايدن هو الاستمرار في تضييع الوقت
وليس تقديم افكار جاده على طاوله
المفاوضات في الواقع تقديم افكار جديده
غير مالوفه الرئيس يتحدث عن زياده الضرائب
لقد اوضحنا منذ البدايه اننا لن نرفع
الضرائب
في المقابل اعتبر رئيس التجمع الديمقراطي
في مجلس النواب بيتر اغويلار ان
الجمهوريين محتجزون من قبل الجناح
المتطرفه في حزبهم
الديمقراطيون في مجلس النواب على
التخفيضات المدمره للمساعدات الغذائيه
للمعلمين او التخفيف يحتاج رئيس مجلس
النواب مكرفي الى ان يكون جادا الطرفان
متمسكان بشروطهما ويتبادلان التهمه حول
ازمه الدين الذي ارتفع من نحو خمسه
تريليونات دولار عام 2000 الى اكثر من 31
تريليون دولار هذا العام
اذا عدت الى الفتره التي كان فيها الرئيس
كلينتون في منصبه ثم غادره فقد ترك في
الواقع فائضا بمئات ملايين الدولارات التي
اعادها الى الاغنياء عبر التخفيضات
الضريبيه ثم بدات حرب العراق وافغانستان
بزياده العجز الى الرقم اليوم وادى الركود
عام 2008 الى تفاقم المشكله ولعل الحل
الوحيد المتبقي للازمه الحاليه وفق خبراء
هو رفع موجز لسقف الدين لفتره زمنيه محدده
لاعطاء مزيد من الوقت للطرفين لمواصله
العمل على القضيه يدور الحديث الان في
واشنطن على ان المشرعين قد يبقون في
العاصمه خلال عطله نهايه الاسبوع الطويله
التي تتزامن مع عيد العمال من اجل التوصل
الى حل للازمه حسين الطاوضه العربيه
واشنطن
ومن واشنطن معنا خبير السياسه الخارجيه
الامريكيه دكتور وليد فارس دكتور وليد
اهلا بك معنا هل ستتخلف امريكا اكبر
اقتصاد في العالم عن سداد دينها
هذا السؤال الاكبر هنا اليوم في العاصمه
وكما تفضلتم في تقاريركم هذا هو السؤال
الكبير فيما يتعلق بالحل الاقتصادي
الداخلي الامريكي وقد فصلتم بوضوح المشاكل
هنالك ثلاثه مشاكل اذا حاولت ان الخصها
بسرعه عناوين العنوان الاول هي صرف
ميزانيات هائله من قبل الادارات اداره
في اخر السنه لها واخر سنتين في اداره تحت
اداره بايدن على مكافحه
على مكافحه الكورونا ولكن باعداد وباحجام
كبيره جدا تعودت
دكتور
دكتور وليد
دكتور وليد فارس يبدو اننا فقدنا الاتصال
معه دكتور وليد اذا كنت تسمعني للمره
الاخيره
فقدنا الاتصال مع الدكتور وليد لعلنا نعود
اليه بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه كشفت صحيفه
حصلت على رساله الكترونيه ارسلت عام 2017
الى الملياردير الامريكي الاشهر بيل جيتس
بدا وكانها تهديد بفضح علاقته الغراميه مع
الروسيه ميله انتونوفا المفاجئ ان مرسل
هذه الرساله هو جيفري الذي انتحر في سجنه
عام 2019 بتهمه التحرش الجنسي بقصر وسبق
وان اطاح بالعديد من الرؤوس المشهوره حتى
بعد وفاته
هل كان الملياردير الامريكي الاشهر بيل
جيتس على علاقه غراميه مع هذه الشبه
الروسيه الصغيره
احدهم نبش في التاريخ واخرج رساله ابتزاز
الكترونيه عمرها ست سنوات
المرسل جيفري ابستن انتحر منذ اربع سنوات
في سجنه بتهمه ارتكاب جرائم جنسيه
المستقبل
مؤسس مايكروسوفت اسرار جفر ابستن
الملياردير الذي كان مولعا بالقاصرات يبدو
انها لم تدفن معه مازال قادرا على احراج
العديد من المشاهير بعد وفاته وفق صحيفه
وول ستريت جورنال هدد جفري بيل جيتس عبر
البريد الالكتروني بفضح علاقته الغراميه
مع الفتاه الروسيه ميلا انتونوفا والتي
حدثت عام 2010
لعبت انتونوفا مع غيتس لعبه بريج
وهذا الشاب لم يصدقني احد السنه الماضيه
لعبت ضده على نفس الطاوله في اتحاد لعبه
بريدج في واشنطن لم اهزمه لكنني حاولت
ركله
انتقلت انتونوفا للعمل كمهندسه برمجيات في
منطقه بيه وكانت قد اقرت بوجود علاقه وديه
تجمعها
بينما ابقى جيتس الامر سرا ربما خشيه من
زوجته ميلاندا التي انفصلت عنه قبل نحو
عامين
اجتمع وتشارك موائد الطعام مرارا
هذه اللقاءات كانت خطا ولم تسفر عن نتائج
كما وعدنا ولقد اوقفتها تماما وهذا كان
منذ زمن بعيد جدا ولا يوجد شيء جديد حولها
لا احد يعلم ما اخفته تلك اللقاءات ربما
بانتظار منقب اخر يحرج جيتس او ملياردير
اخر اغرته قاصره جفري
ونعود الى ضيفنا من واشنطن دكتور وليد
فارس يعود الينا دكتور وليد كنا نتحدث عن
ازمه الدين الامريكي وكنت تتحدث عن
الاسباب كنت اتحدث على الانفاق الكبير في
مجال كورونا
الانفاق الكبير في مجال الكورونا قلت سنه
تحت ترامب اقل تسعه اشهر تحت ترامب وسنتين
ونيف تحت بيض وقد جرى هذا الصرف الكبير
تحت بايدن تحت طهط بالطبع حزبه اولا
بالنسبه للانتخابات وبعد ذلك الاوضاع
الداخليه اثنين الانتاج النفطي يعني اداره
بيض اوقفت الانتاج النفطي الامريكي الذي
كان يعني يساعد جدا في تسعير هذه السلع
وثالثا ربما والان يناقش كثيرا هو الدعم
اللام المتناهي لاوكرانيا بالسيوله
وبالنزانيه نعم ما الذي يبحث عنه
الجمهوريون وكفن ماكارسي دكتور وليد
من ناحيه هم لا يحبون الديون بشكل عام ولا
يحبون الصرف بشكل خاص ولكن من ناحيه اخرى
لا يجب ان يبين يظهروا الراي العام انهم
غير مهتمون بالحياه اليوميه وهذه نقطه قوه
عندها بيض وعندها حزبه انه يظهرهم نفسهم
انهم او الاشتراكيون المعتدلين الى ما
هنالك يهتمون بالشعب والصرف عليه بينما
جمهوريون يهتمون بالاقتصاد ككل البرتبط
بقدره اقتصاد الرب تحت الامريكيه ان ينفذ
المشاريع وبالتالي ان يقضي على هذه نعم
طيب ما هي الشروط ما هي الشروط التي يضعها
الجمهوريون حتى يرفعوا سقف الدين
شروط ان تخفف هذه الاداره من صرفها على
مواضيع كثيره يعني تذهب من المواضيع
الاجتماعيه وهنالك خلاف كبير حولها يعني
يعرف
هذه من ناحيه ومن ناحيه ثانيه الاهم
باعتقادي ان يفرضوا على بيض ان يفتح
انابيب النفط ان يفتح الانتاج وخاصه الاتي
من كندا
بنصح نعم لو لم
يتمكن بايضا من الاتفاق مع الجمهوريين
وتخلفت امريكا بالفعل عن سداد ديونها هل
سيؤثر علينا هذا في الدول العربيه وفي
الشرق الاوسط والخليج
سيؤثر على العالم باسره على العالم باسره
الاقتصاد الامريكي عندما يواجه صعوبات
بالطبع سوف يكون هنالك تاثير حجم التاثير
لا نعرف حتى الان
نعم شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور وليد فارس الخبير
في السياسه الخارجيه الامريكيه كنت معنا
من واشنطن
وبعد قليل في اخبار الساعه بيع ساعه يد
لاخر امبراطور للصين بالسته.2 مليون دولار
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد تمكن متسلق الجبال
النيبالي كاميراتا الملقب برجل ايفرست من
الوصول الى قمه احلى جبل في العالم للمره
الثامنه والعشرين محطما رقمه القياسيه
السابق بعد يوم واحد من نجاحه نيفالي اخر
يدعى بسنج دواء شيربا في معادلته
قمه يتنافس عليها الشبان ويتصدرها رجل
خمسيني لسنوات بلغها لاول مره في
المتسلق النيبالي كاميرتا يتفوق على نفسه
للمره الثامنه والعشرين
لكن شخصا واحدا من النيباليين نافسه بقوه
على اعلى سطح في العالم وفعلا حقق الشاب
الاربعيني باسانداوا تعادلا مع خصمه
كاميرته
لكن الاخيره لم يستصغ ان يعتلي الصداره
احد سواه وبعد يوم لملم عده التسلق مجددا
خلال اسبوع وحطم الرقم القياسي متجاوزا ما
تعادل فيه مع نظيره وفاق ثمانيه الاف
وثمانمائه وتسعه واربعين مترا ليستحق لقب
رجل ايفرست بجداره
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا ان ننوه فقط الى هذا العاجل ظهر
على الشاشه العربيه الخارجيه السعوديه اذا
تؤكد ان المملكه وامريكا تجددان التاكيد
على اهميه اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار في
السودان وبان الشعب السوداني بحاجه
لمساعدات الانسانيه وعوده الخدمات
الاساسيه اقامت الملكه رانيا العبد الله
عقيله العائله الاردنيه حفله حناء في
مضارب بني هاشم بالعاصمه الاردنيه عمان
بمناسبه قرب زفاف ولي العهد الامير حسين
بن عبد الله الثاني والانسه رجوى السيف
المقرر في الاول من يونيو المقبل وشارك في
حفل الحنه عدد من اميرات العائله الملكيه
والسيدات حضرنا من مختلف محافظات البلاد
[موسيقى]
فاتوره التغييرات المناخيه تكلف البشره
الشيء الكثير سواء في الارواح والممتلكات
فالارقام المسجله على امتداد 50 عاما تثير
القلق حول التاثير الكبير للتغيرات
المناخيه بهذا الخصوص اظهر تقرير لمنظمه
العالميه للارصاد الجويه ان انماط الطقس
القاسيه تسببت بوفاه اكثر من مليوني شخص
في العالم وبخسائر تقدر بنحو 4.3 تريليون
دولار فذلك خلال مده 50 عاما
[موسيقى]
اشترى جامع مقتنيات اسيوي ساعه نادره كانت
مملوكه لاخر امبراطور في اسره تشينغ
الصينيه بمبلغ وصف بالقياسي والبالغ سته
ملايين دولار في مزاد في هونغ كونغ وبيعت
الساعه من طراز باعلى سعر قياسي سجل لسعه
يد مملوكه لامبراطور وفقا لدار
حصدت قناه العربيه 38 جائزه من بينها خمس
جوائز من الفئه الذهبيه من جوائز تيلي
التي تعنى بتكريم التميز في مجال
التلفزيون والفيديو المزيد في التقرير
التالي
ثمان وثلاثون جائزه نصيب قناه العربيه من
جوائز تالي العالميه في نسختها 44
الجائزه التي تنظم السنويا في الولايات
المتحده تقدم لارفع الانتاجات التلفزيونيه
وتقدم في فئات ثلاثه
ذهبيه وفضيه مبرونسي
الجائزه تعد واحده من اهم الجوائز
المتخصصه في مجال تقييم محتوى الفيديو
والانتاج المرئي بمشاركه بئتي خبير من
مؤسسه اعلاميه وقنوات وشركات انتاج دوليه
ضمن الفئات التي ربحت جائزه التالي خمس
جوائز ذهبيه كانت من نصيبي ثلاثه برامج
وتغطيتين على الصعيد البرامج برنامج على
خطى العرب ومهمه خاصه وعسكري تاريا اما
على الصعيد التغطيه فكانت من نصيب تغطيه
الانتخابات النصفيه الامريكيه وكذلك تقرير
نفذ بتقنيه الواقع الافتراضي من هو
جوائز تالي التي حازتها قناه العربيه كانت
ضمنها عشرون جائزه فضيه وثلاثه عشره جائزه
من الفئه البرونزيه
ذهبت لعدد من برامج العربيه وتغطياتها
الخاصه الاقتصاديه والسياسيه والوثائقيه
وبرامجها على مواقع التواصل والتصميم
الابداعي واستخدام الواقع المعزز
جوائز تيل العالميه الفئه الذهبيه البرامج
على خطى العرب مهمه خاصه
عسكري تاريا
التغطيات الانتخابات النصفيه الامريكيه
تقرير بتقنيه الواقع الافتراضي من هو
بايدن
شادينا نعود ان نذكر في ختام اخبار الساعه
بالاخبار العاجله المزيد منها ترد عن
الخارجيه السعوديه اذا التي اكدت ان
المملكه وامريكا تجددان بالتاكيد على
اهميه اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار في السودان
الخارجيه السعوديه اضافت بان الشعب
السوداني بحاجه ماسه للمساعده الانسانيه
وعوده الخدمات الاساسيه كذلك اكدت
الخارجيه السعوديه ان الطرفين بالسودان لم
يلتزما بعدم السعي وراى مكاسب عسكريه قبل
وقف اطلاق النار كذلك في هذه المواقف من
قبل الخارجيه السعوديه تؤكد ان المملكه
وامريكا ابلغتها طرفي الصراع في السودان
بوجود انتهاكات لوقف اطلاق النار وبان
المملكه وامريكا تطالبان بالتزام الطرفين
في السودان بوقف اطلاقنا بهذه العواجل
تنتهي اخبار الساعه شكرا على المشاهده الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات